[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality soon to be a number one
bestselling author of the book Breaking
Free from broke is my co-host today open
phones at
5225 Dave starts this hour in Madison
Wisconsin hi Dave welcome to the Ramsey
Show good afternoon hey what's up my my
question is uh my wife and I are on baby
step seven and we want to be able to
help out our kids we have grown adult
kids one of them just got married and
the other one is a grad student in
college and we want to be able to help
them in such a way that you know whether
it's paying you know helping pay for a
down payment on a house or something
like that we we want to help them and
have it be a blessing but not make them
feel entitled or not you know kind of
make them feel like they're just waiting
on us to to
provide are they waiting on you now oh
no no so there's not already a sense of
entitlement you're just worried that
handing them $30,000 might create more
entitlement right H I mean you know we
like throughout the course of them
growing up you know we we paid for their
their State College uh you know they we
basically provided them you know when
they graduated from undergrad you know
we got them a nice reliable used car and
kind of set them on the path and said
all right you're you're you know you're
never going to borrow money to buy stuff
like that you know you're the next car
you buy you're going to save up and pay
cash for it uh you know you're you're
not going to have any student loans um
are they do are they doing all of those
things yeah good well here's the thing I
don't think the gift causes the
entitlement I mean you could give one
person uh a dollar and they would be
entitled and you could give another
person a $100 million doar and they
wouldn't feel
entitled so entitlement is an
arrogance entitled is I am due the I I'm
I'm on third base I was born on third
base walking around acting like I hit a
triple you know and you didn't do squat
you know so entitlement is I am due
something from someone there's an it's
an
arrogance and uh it's my right to get
this I'm entitled to health care I'm
entitled to something and it's you're
it's it's basically saying you're
willing to you
you improperly believe that you have
rights over someone else's
stuff right that make sense so
entitlement is an attitude it's not a
it's not caused by an
amount and so it sounds like you got
really good kids that you're describing
yeah yeah I mean they they worked really
hard for for everything they have I mean
I'm I'm a teacher so uh you know I feel
like they you know they we live in a a
pretty nice suburb and you know the
reason that they had their schooling
paid for is because we didn't go out and
buy all the things that maybe their
friends had and you know we but they
didn't they didn't walk around acting
like that you had to do that or you were
a bad human it was just what you did and
so you know like you know I have a
friend that bought his uh kids when they
got married he bought them up paid for
house and said um you know you the only
thing I ask from you is that you promis
to never borrow money the rest of your
life and uh those kids have gone on to
become millionaires fairly quickly
obviously got a head start with a nice
house you know I mean and they got no
payments so they're piling it up but
those kids were not entitled at all they
they were just grateful and um I know
the kids well and and they were um you
know they've gone on to become normal
grown adults and they just got a real
nice Head Start cuz dad cuz their dad
and mom had done well like you guys so I
I think it's about the attitude uh the
thing you don't want to do I I guess one
thing you could say is just you know
don't develop an expectation with this
gift of this down payment for this house
that I'm always going to be here handing
out money this is a one-time thing and
you can just say that one thing to make
sure there's clarity about it right but
but the entitlement has to do with their
lack of character not about you giving
them a an education or giving them a car
or giving them money for payment does
that make
sense yeah yeah I mean and I guess the
other thing I question I have with that
is you know I want to you know this is a
gift I mean I'm not I know I hear you
constantly talk about how you know when
your kids are grown you can't use your
dad voice anymore you know they're
they're basically we're we're walking
together as as friends and maybe you
know I can be a mentor but you know I
can suggest some things but ultimately
it's it's their choice and so you know
that's the thing my gift would be
contingent upon them you know doing
these things I mean I I don't have to a
promise that they continue to go that
direction and I do have the right to
attach that with a gift I'll give you an
example the Ramsey Family Foundation we
give to a lot of Ministries we do not
give to Ministries that borrow
money and so the gift is contingent
upon you know the that the fact that
that Ministry is not going to go into
debt and and use some of the money I
gave them to pay stinking Bank interest
that'd be stupid Dave Ramsey be giving
people money for that right so I mean
that but that's a gift that has control
on it and you know if there's going to
be a gift in another year uh that g the
follow-up gift will not happen if they
have borrowed money during that year we
stop them you know so it's the same
thing but that that so it's okay to put
a to attach a contingency to a gift yeah
and I I think the worry for our friend
Dave here is that he's worried his gener
generosity of trying to offer them this
blessing will turn into laziness but he
hasn't raised lazy kids so this will not
cause that to happen the gift in and of
itself doesn't cause that to happen I
mean it can it could be part of the
equation that caused it I mean if you
got a trust fund baby that's waiting on
okay I'm going to you know at age 30
you're going to get $2 million and so
they decide well I'm not going to work
much I'm just going to sit around wait
till I hit 30 well but the problem was
it was not just the $2 million at age 30
the the problem was the person you
raised to be that freaking lazy you know
that mediocre mindset and so the fact
that you plugged that into them before
you made this announcement about this
trust gift and so that's the problem
with a trust fund baby you know right
there the classic
stereotype because that's a sense of
entitlement well you've said that an
eagle that doesn't uh is it a turkey an
eagle that doesn't leave the nest is
called a turkey right I love that and
that's I think the worry for every
parent out there but he's saying hey my
kids are getting an education they have
jobs they're getting married they're not
stuck in Mom's basement and he's going
here's $30,000 that's a very different
you got you should be in order for uh a
parent in Dave situation to come
alongside and start dumping money on the
situation you should be that they should
already be on fire and you're just
adding some fluid you're adding a little
gas to the fire not like wet wood is
sitting there and we're going to throw
some gas on it hope it lights up that's
a little different that's the difference
right I mean so you're all you're doing
is trying to accentuate the good things
that are already happening further those
good things that are already happening
not but you're not going to with a gift
like wet wood so the kid needs to
already be on fire that's the deal this
is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey guys Ramsey Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
net site it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million dollar Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us America we appreciate you we
appreciate you sharing the show click
the share button following and
subscribing and leaving five-star
reviews and all those good things thank
you when you click subscribe or follow
or you click the share button or you
take a link and you share it or you tell
somebody where you're listening on talk
radio it changes our life around here
it's our rankings our ratings on every
platform have gone up dramatically in
the past 12 months and it's largely
we're blaming it on you because you
shared it thank you George is a big deal
isn't it huge and I we hit number one on
that all podcast recently which was just
mind blowing number one on Apple big
time we wereing in the same show and
which tells me it's largely due to all
of the folks out there who are helping
us share the spread the word yeah we
didn't suddenly get smarter it didn't I
wish I could say that had one amazing
show did it Dave we had a breakthrough
no we didn't just still here doing what
we do Linda's and Phenix he Linda how
are
you hi good good how can we
help um so my husband and I we currently
own a home we've been here for 12 years
we have a really awesome interest rate
on it low mortgage and we are thinking
about buying another house and we want
to keep our current home as an
investment property but I'm just a
little bit um worried that it's going to
strap us financially too much and just
kind of wanted to get your thoughts I
wouldn't you wouldn't buy it no I mean
I'd sell the house and buy another house
but I wouldn't keep your other house I
know that because you have a mortgage on
it
and your first your first goal your
first goal to becoming wealthy one of
the top two things you need to do
there's two big things to get to the
first million to 5 million in net worth
is get your residents paid for be 100%
debt free and build up your retirement
in mutual funds those are the two
primary things that cause people to get
their first one to5 million it is
not leveraged
borrowed rental property that is not
what causes the typical first 1 to 5
million all the research we've done
studying 10,000 millionaires so uh
everybody talks about how good rental
property is rental property is wonderful
if it's paid for and your home is paid
for but that's not the situation you're
in okay so you say this house needs to
be paid off before if we wanted to have
well and you would need to pay cash for
the next
house okay yeah we couldn't do
I know I can tell let's pretend you were
sitting in a paid for home and you
wanted to buy a rental property I would
tell you to do that with cash it's what
I by the way done property with cash
everything with cash never buy real
estate with
that because here's what happens you you
you don't make as much on them because
you you're eating up your cash flow of
payments and you you all of a sudden the
way you're dealing with the tenant
changes because you need the rent money
to pay the
payment you know how much I need rent P
I've got I've got bunch of real estate
you know how much the I have to collect
the rent on any of it none of it because
I don't have any debt and so I don't
have to put a bad tenant in there hoping
they'll pay because I got to make the
bank
note okay that makes sense yeah there's
no desperation when you do it that way
and your your worry that you mentioned
that's wisdom that's your body telling
you this is not a good idea and so doing
it this way it's going to take longer
but you're going to do it with a lot of
peace and a lot of patience yeah so if I
were going to move in your situation I
would just sell that house move the
equity to the next property get that
personal residence paid off and then
start saving and pay cash for your first
rental that by the way is exactly what I
did the second time I built wealth the
first time I was a millionaire I did it
with borrowed money on real estate and I
went bankrupt and lost everything
because I was leveraged up to my
eyeballs and I was
stupid so I wasn't stupid what I was
doing was stupid and if you're out there
doing it you're not stupid but what
you're doing is really stupid so there
we go well then Dave this was another
part I love she said uh we've been here
12 years I love the interest rate I
don't love the house I just love the
interest rate people are hanging on to
do you the interest rate that you have
no cuz I don't rate you have is zero
it's a wonderful love your interest rate
thank you I love my interest rate it's
zero I don't have an interest rate but
that's the toxic money culture Dave
they're saying you should get obsessed
with a low interest rate a low payment
that's the key now the key is be if
you're going to borrow to buy your home
date the rate marry the house the
interest rate should be looked at as a
temporary thing not something we're
going to keep around like a family
heirloom so Cas it on to my
grandkids good one we're going to make
sure everybody gets you little no that's
not that's right though that's how
people talk about it and that's not
making fun of her that's just what but
that's how people think in America today
so Linda what we're always big on around
here is getting you out of debt keeping
you out of debt because it is the
shortest most sustainable way to build
wealth the shortest path to proven
wealth building because you don't have
any payments you have money and then you
get to buy more stuff and help more
people and be more generous Chris is in
New York City hey Chris welcome to the
Ramsey Show
now hi Dave hi George thanks for taking
my call sure what's
up well I am hoping to get some advice
from you uh in terms of streamlining and
uh streamlining and um simplifying our
investments uh we rent right now uh we
also uh our business uh is mortgaging a
property and that's uh we have about 350
left in the mortgage but we also own
outright a rental property that's uh
probably worth about 200 and I have we
have my wife and I have um about
55,000 in a whole life policy and 65 in
stocks and I was thinking maybe we
should sell the rental and then cash out
uh the life insurance policy and the
stocks to pay off either pay off the
mortgage on the business building or to
buy a place to live outright so I was
hoping to you could help me Shi some
light
Oh either one of those would be a
wonderful idea neither NE I mean either
one's fine with me if you buy a home
then what we're going to do is lean over
next and start using cash flow to start
paying off the the business mortgage if
you pay off the mortgage we're going to
use the cash flow to start saving up to
buy house either way so um I mean at the
end of the story both properties are
debt free and uh that that end is not
that far down the road I mean at the end
of 3 to 5 years from today that's where
you ought to be what's your household
income
uh we make uh about 120 a year okay all
right right and uh what what has made it
so difficult is our rent is just really
our landl has been wonderful and the
rent has been so cheap but yeah that's
that's nice started listening to you
about a month ago you know and I feel
like yeah it's it's it's time to make
things simpler yeah and and I like I
like your idea of Simplicity but also
you know the you may have cheap rent but
that property's going up in value in his
name
that's you're you're right you're right
about that yeah you want to be an owner
not a laner man so you'll get there I
would do this move anyways I would cash
out this whole life policy I'm selling
the stocks and I think simplifying your
life without the volatility of the
stocks without the crappiness of that
whole life policy you're life's going to
be better yeah and get rid of the rental
and buy you a home I you get you another
rental later on down the road yeah I
mean you make good money and you get the
business paid off and uh you're sitting
there really making some serious money
no house payment No Business Payment
boom boom we've got what we call margin
at that point increased cash flow cash
flow yeah money's flying everywhere you
start stacking cash at that point and
you can get your um I mean you get
yourself in a really really pretty
position the thing snowballs in the
right direction you know because the
more the stuff you own that you don't
have payments and you got a good income
uh you know it starts feeding on itself
and all of a sudden you look over there
and where's all this money coming from
oh I'm not giving it all to the bank I'm
not supporting those Towers in the
skyline that has Furniture nicer than I
have it is amazing when you look at the
rental property numbers people share and
they go I'm go how much you making a
year off of this 1,200 bucks 100 bucks a
month I'm like you're doing all of this
for $1,200 which also means by the way
they're probably losing money oh yeah at
the end of the day I mean that's that's
not our friend on the call here but
that's many people out there they're
doing too much at once fiddling around
trying to skip ahead you have a $100 a
month cash flow you're not making money
cuz um I mean one heating an air filter
and you're done you know oh my God
you're in the red just one little thing
one little one little sink issue you're
done yeah ah there's no no room in that
that's no fun this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
own family has an eligible medical event
chm has been a godsend for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
George camel Ramsey personality co-host
of smart money happy hour with Rachel
Cruz he's my co-host today open phones
atle
88255 225 Michael is with us Michael's
in Louisville Kentucky hey Michael how
are you great how are you better than I
deserve what's
up um my girlfriend and I are being uh
getting married this year and um we are
combining households um we both have she
has a grown child and I have two kids
that are getting ready to go into
college and U just trying to see what's
the best way to kind of combine uh you
know with a blended family and assets
you know previous assets and things like
that um what's the best way of going
about combining that fairly where you
know my kids are taking care of the way
I've been planning for years and and and
obviously her S as well with her
own h
well it it's an emotional series of
decisions um and uh I'm I'm not I'm not
sure there's a wrong way or a right way
to do it it's whatever you guys sit down
and come up with is the right way I I
don't think there's an immoral or a
moral issue or an Ethics issue um I'm
old school on
kids and so our kids understood when
they were growing up that the number one
thing in my life was not
them it was their mother understand it
was their
mother and they gets their second right
behind their mother but don't get
between me and your mother you that
won't work well for you and so uh were I
to remarry if Sharon were to pass away
um I would have the same concerns that
you've got but I would want to my first
goal would be to that to take care of my
wife sure and so my second my second
goal would be if there's anything left
we can help the kids but they're like
supposed to be grown-ups and on their
own correct and I agree um I guess more
of a technical question too was you know
um maybe not uh I have a home that's
paid for and she has a home that's still
got a mortgage on it other than that we
don't have any debt um I have a 401k and
my retirement and all that m um
basically she has basically her home is
her asset that she's been thinking of
leaving to her kids or her child you
know but someday or it be her really her
only asset that I'm going to combine my
home sell mine entirely and put all of
that into hers to start to pay off a big
chunk of the morgage and do some
improvements and then we which will
change her plan that would change her
plan if you're going to be living there
and she dies and it's her and the house
is going to her kids she's going to make
her new husband
homeless correct after put m is there a
way to yes I guess that's a way how do
you how do you lay things out where I
don't I don't know I guess to put her
mind at ease I'm not really sure how to
word that where you know things will be
there's not a there there there's um I
mean you could you you could start using
a bunch of trusts and have putting
things into a trust and the trust has
certain terms to it and you're going to
spend a ton of money on that um and um
but I I think what you're feeling is a
natural tension and I would feel the
same tension if I were in your shoes and
I'm validating that but I think the two
of you have got to decide okay what is
more important to the two of you if
you're going to take several hundred, do
dump it into her house right and now it
becomes our house oh but wait it's going
to her kids well that's screwed up
that's going to create a problem and so
maybe her CH her plan is going to change
now you know yeah maybe her new husband
is going to get the house if she does
and uh really in my my thoughts were
whoever goes first obviously the other
person that's is everything is theirs
and then when they're
gone it can go you know three ways to
everybody and divide it up however you
know yeah you can leave the portion that
was going to be her house to her kid and
portion that was going to be your stuff
to your kids I mean there's no there's
no right or wrong thing and it's not
wrong to leave the house to her kid if
she wanted to it just leaves you
homeless and it's really weird it feel
it feels awkward you know but I have
seen that I've seen where the the stepar
parent gets kicked out upon
death yeah and it can be really
um emotionally strenuous that's a nice
way of saying it yeah so I I think the
why what I want to encourage you is
really push through and don't the
problem with the other plan is okay you
leave it all to her she leaves it all to
you if if you don't do that in a trust
that states how things are going to be
distributed then the surviving spouse
could change their will after the death
of the like say she passed away first
she left everything to you four years
later you're getting married
again you could change the whole will
again and her kid ends up getting
nothing you legally Legally it be
immoral it'd be unethical for you to do
that but but legally there's no way to
keep that from happening except to dump
it all into a trust upon death and the
trust has certain terms and the terms
are the distribution you know maybe
based on the past evaluation to to the
kiddos upon your death or or something
like that cuz you're you're not going to
be able to undo that those trust terms
so you'd have to see an estate planner
to do that that would be a mechanical
way a tactical way to pull it off now
Dave would it be simpler to turn this
into Cash let's say they sell the
property and she would get that amount
let's say of the Equity as it stands
today in an investment account would
that simplify things well she's I mean
then he's buying the only house cuz they
have two houses right now the pay for
one and the mortgage one yeah but I'm
saying the uh either way she's either
got her cash sitting over here to the
side but if she passes away she's just
going to leave that cash nothing to her
husband you know everything to her kid I
you know so the key is there's there's a
lot of ways to SK this cap but we have
to be in agreement with both spouses
which is the hardest part yeah and uh
and just promising that you'll do it in
your will is not binding legally I'm not
an attorney but you find that out when
you go sit with your estate planning
attorney that's what they're going to
tell you so but leaving it into a trust
you could do that you could set terms of
the trust and it's locked in there's
nothing you can do about it if I was in
their shoes I'd sit with the estate
planning attorney have them lay out all
of the options and then we agree which
is the best route yeah and then but
here's the thing you part of what you're
struggling with is before they met her
children were her were her everything
even though they're grown his children
since she's divorced or his wife's P
first wife passed away whatever his
children are his only concern priority
wise but and and this new relationship
changes the priority the spouse now
takes it
challenges the priority position it in
your emotion and so that that's the hard
thing to walk through and it's very real
I mean I I I haven't had to do it thank
God but um but you know it is a very
very real thing it's it's
um you know but you I like to think that
I would want to make sure my new wife
was taken care of before I worried about
my grown kids you'd hope the kid would
understand but I'm sure it causes
relational turmoil I don't care I don't
care I mean it's it's you know what is
what's the primary relationship who's
your first team then who's your second
team and that's what we're talking about
here and so the kiddos growing up
understood they second team you know we
love you they're the be team and we'll
take a bullet for you um but but you
know you know your your mom's coming
first your mom's in front of you in
priority that's how work I love the idea
of the kids being so self-sustaining
they're not needing whatever's on the
other side yeah and that changes the
whole equation when somebody doesn't
feel entitled to it or need it the kid
says well that was my one shot at home
ownership was getting mom's house and
now you ruined it well they feel like
the dad's assets are somehow they're
entitled to them they're not entitled to
them you have absolutely no moral or
ethical obligation to leave your
children
money so your kids doing heroin don't
leave them money you'll kill them
because you will leave them enough to
buy enough heroin to kill themselves so
you you you know if you're you know
think whatever other fill in the blank
of
said misbehavior you will magnify the
misbehavior so you I am under no
obligation to leave my children money
and by the way that's very clear around
our place they're grown and we're like
you know you you're I manage these
assets for God if you're not walking
with God then you don't have the
opportunity to manage his assets boom
you're out Sorry Sorry Charlie just like
that Charlie yeah King Charles Rachel's
smallest yes and he is a king he sleeps
on a queen bed already so that's the
most impressive part saying I'm just
saying
yeah that's a neque question Michael and
I I I struggle with you on it but I
encourage you to get closure on it don't
just assume because you know what that
does yeah this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people you're
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blind .c rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply George camel personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
5225 all right America ready for Pop
Quiz what percentage of Americans say
they live paycheck to
paycheck oh pick me pick
me oh oh the the the the big guy in the
front row that's me George I'm going to
go seven out of 10 yeah this this survey
says 65%
say they do six and a half people out of
10 there we go half a person yeah and
the um you know I've heard as high as
78% actually do so somewhere around
seven houses out of 10 on your street
have too much month left at the end of
the
money looking good and broke BR r k e
broke sitting at a stoplight burning gas
they bought on a credit card or Worse
electricity that they find financed on a
credit C oh yikes pick it on George here
that's even worse yeah so you can stay
stuck in the
cycle paycheck to paycheck rat in a
wheel or you can change something stupid
has a gravitational
pull once you get stuck in the orbit
around stupid it's hard to break the
orbit and you just keep going and going
and going and going and you're the wrong
kind of ever ready bunny right just a
rat and a wheel just going and going and
going no traction living a life of
mediocrity no hope not fired up that's
most people you don't want to be like
that let me tell you how you get out of
an orbit even if it's orbiting stupid
you have to expend energy to break the
orbit you have to break the cycle break
the family curse break the way you grew
up and the way you look at things the
way they talked in your neighborhood the
way they the kids I hung out with at
work well little man can't get
ahead Thank God It's Friday oh God it's
mondy we're all just stuck sure hope we
can elect a president who'll fix my life
cuz I'm not going to do anything about
it yes you grow up around that man I'm
telling you that's the worst country eor
is your spirit animal I mean come on
seriously yeah so to kick off the year
we're going to help you we're going to
host a free live stream this Thursday
January the 11th at 700 p.m. central
352,000 people have already registered
it's the largest live stream we've ever
done it's officially the largest it's me
Dave Ramsey Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz
George camel to my right and Jade washaw
are going to talk about navigating money
anxiety bad money habits that keep you
stuck and how to break them practical
money tips that actually work we're
going to help you break the cycle and
we're going to give away $110,000 10
people are going to get $1,000 each
during the viewing you have to be
watching or you're not going to get it
cuz that's going to be part of the deal
okay so if you want to sign up you want
to watch we would love to have you this
Thursday night at 7 o' Breaking the
cycle you go to ramsy solutions.com
breakthe cycle it's completely free by
the way completely free hello did I
mention it's free amazing and it's gonna
be about an hour long so I'm just
picturing if you just spend one hour
with us hanging out on a free live
stream it could change how this whole
year goes for you financially if we can
change how you think and how you look at
this then it'll change what you do and
if we can help you change what you do
then you're going to change your results
and your results will change your life
now we're not going to change your life
you're going to go do it you're the hero
in the story we're just going to show
you how we really know how to do this
we're going to break you free from the
orbit and get you on a different path
yeah just just you know this is you
you've been believing some stuff you
didn't need to believe you you're better
than your belief well especially going
to an election year I feel like everyone
just gets angry everybody's worried
about inflation the anxiety is so high
out there they're worried about interest
rates man I'm worried about is the
market going to crash I'm worried about
this worried about that and let me tell
you what we can show you what to do we
can show you the process and it's it's
not magical it's not get rich quick it's
not easy I mean we're going to teach you
important things like live on less than
you make you ready to do that there's a
whole new idea concept Congress can't
grasp Nica is with us in Jacksonville
Florida hi Nia welcome to the Ramsey
Show Oh Mr Ramsey thank you so much for
taking my call hope all as well with you
um so I I in my 20s I listen to your
read your books and such purchased a
home at 27 um however I lost my job
after 10 years and I sold my condo in
2016 I live at home I'm now 42 and I
created a lot of thatt for myself but I
want to purchase a condo in 202 5 so I
just wanted your advice and a strategy
on how what what debt to pay down first
um I have $10,000 in total debt um three
personal loans three credit cards and I
have
$45,000 student loan debt I'm still in
school seeking my masters and I'll be
done at the end of the year so I'm not
currently paying that right now I have
$3
36,42 my 401k I I know I borrowed from
my 401k um $20,000 to pay off my debt
which I accured again um so right now by
weekly I'm paying 17194 at 4.5% interest
on my
401k all right so what is your total
debt outside of uh you you don't have a
mortgage now so what's your total
Consumer Debt 10 10 plus 45 plus 20 on
the 401
right yes 75 65 sorry no the 401 is 30
36,42 no the blown balance the loan on
the 401 is oh I'm sorry um $14,000 left
to pay oh 14 on that okay yeah and it's
171 by weekly on my paycheck and a 4 so
you got about $70,000 in debt and you
make
what um right now it just got raised so
6,400 I you know wasn't making much but
now I am making more and I recently paid
off my car in 2021 unless your income
changes you're not going to buy a house
in 25
right what's your Ms in what what a
condo I wanted a condo I'm I work in
education um I work in education so it's
obviously you don't create that much in
education so will this Masters increase
your income condo um not much then why
are you doing it's required well it's
required um right now I'm not paying for
it the school pays for it and because I
work in education it's required to have
a higher degree but the school pays 90%
of that
Nia you need to pay off
$70,000 say save up a down save up an
emergency fund then save up a down
payment well right now I have uh $3,500
I just don't don't know if I should but
I have three personal loans um 35 35 25
yeah and you have 45,000 in student loan
debt and you have $20,000 on a 401K you
have $70,000 in
debt okay I didn't look at it like that
but yes so here's the hard truth you're
not going to be ready to buy a house a
year from now it may be two or three
years from now wow we have to get rid of
the debt you don't have 70,000 coming
in in the next 12 months you have 60,000
coming in and you have 70,000 in
thatt right yeah um what I was thinking
maybe I should pay off my save up this
year pay off you know my uh 401K the
$14,000 just slat out paid off or if I
should pay the high interest rate that I
have on the personal loan I think we're
beyond the math of interest rates I
would just list all of your debts out
from smallest to largest make minimum
payments on all the debts except for the
smallest one and we're going to attack
that one with a Vengeance as much extra
on the principle as you can throw at it
and that might mean you're doing side
jobs after your master's program after
your full-time job when and you complete
your Masters when and the end of this
year so 12 more months uhhuh okay
all right do you have any time to do
tutoring during while you're working on
your
Masters not really I mean the job is is
pretty demanding you know sometimes I do
have to work weekends now you said
you're living at home with your
parents yes okay so you have almost no
expenses what are you having to pay for
right now the loans that I have and the
credit cards um I do give them
contribute $600 but it's the loans that
I have personal loans you know
situations happen and obviously I did
that but okay honey you're going to have
to draw a line in the S and quit
borrowing money I don't hear anymore
about your situations you've situation
yourself into your parents basement you
got to quit situation so um cut up the
credit cards get yourself on a beans and
rice rice and beans budget anything you
can do to increase your income like
tutoring let's go do it and uh let's
start attacking these debts just exactly
like George said smallest to
largest and it's going to take you a
little while to clear $70,000 in debt
when you get that clear you can talk
talk about buying a house you may go
rent something in the meantime but I
wouldn't buy until you get this mess
cleaned
[Music]
[Applause]
up
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
[Music]
225 starting this hour off is going to
be Jenny in Columbus Ohio hi Jenny
welcome to the ramsy show hi thanks for
having me sure how can we
help uh my husband and I are on baby set
two and we are all in I've got a second
job he's working overtime we're selling
everything but our kid um we're all in
however um we are looking at anywhere
depending on what option we pick at the
dentist we're looking at anywhere from10
to $50,000 worth of work needed on my
husband's
teeth um I don't know how to do that
without taking on more
debt what's your household
income1
170 well I do you save up $10,000
well okay so the
$110,000 um gets us 10 years they said
and then he'd probably have to have the
work done again do you still think
that's the best option or should we wait
or should we try to do the $50,000
option which is a fix for the rest of
his
life
um B or C none of the above I want you
to go I want you to go talk to two other
dentists okay I'm calling
BS okay unless your husband has some
kind of
disease
50,000 is out of
control I am not a medical professional
impants it's for dental implants I know
but it's not okay then it's not 50 Grand
let's go shopping let's go shopping okay
okay okay um because the the thing I I I
I don't know beans about being a dentist
okay uh but what I do know from having
sat in this chair for 30 years is that
I've had a lot of people bring me
dramatic numbers like you just did and I
send them back to the marketplace and
they there's a lot of other ways to do
this and turns out and a lot of uh
different pricing structures and so
forth for some reason when it comes to
medical or dental or things like this we
we don't shop like we if if you were
buying a car and someone said you could
buy a $50,000 car or a $10,000 car you
would say okay uh tell me about it and
and and then I'm going to keep looking
at cars I'm going to keep shopping and
then I'm going to have a lot of things
to compare with not just two of these
options so but for some reason all of us
you included uh just accept well it's
50,000 bucks ad dentist said so um doc
said it's this and no there's you
know vast array of pricing structures in
that world so I want to go shopping and
then yes I'll put let's pretend you can
fix this for 10 or 15,000 bucks or
20,000 bucks even okay for implants okay
something more permanent and then you
know have to cheap out but you also
don't have to go bananas okay so
um then then the answer to your question
is how do you pull that off you make 170
you just slow your dead snowball and
pile up 20 grand depending on the
urgency the amount of pain he's in or
whatever is you're facing is how fast
you do it uh if it's me and I'm hurting
we're going to do it fast cuz I'm a
complete wuss you want to over with
quickly I I I don't do pain I'm a wuss
Sharon has the pain tolerance of a Navy
SEAL uh get a hang nail and I'm in the
floor crying like a four-year-old so no
I mean so I'm going to go I'm going to
write some checks yeah and get out of
pain is what I'm going to do but anyway
so just depending on the urgency of the
situation and if what she's saying is
true let's say 10,000 buys are 10 years
well 10 years from now you're going to
be in a very different place financially
in two years it might be debt free and
you could do whatever you want I don't
know if I want to rent my teeth for 10
years but anyway I'm confus I didn't
know it was like an HVAC like well this
thing will keep it running for the next
10 years I don't know what they're doing
to his mouth there it's a very
strange well diagnosis I I can tell you
this there's
um the cost it's $400 and something
thousand to become a dentist now and
then buying into a practice would be
another half million or so and so
there's a
whole business side of
Dentistry that allows them to
sell a vast array of products I've
fallen for it every time I go in there
they have a new technology they've
purchased that can now do the new thing
and it's for $50 a tooth we can do this
for you otherwise it'll be 300 later on
if you get the cavity and I'm like I
don't it's so stressful that's called
practice
management sales which is medical talk
for sales okay so um I I I'm not
accusing this dentist of malpractice I'm
just saying he's willing to sell
implants are the most will to sell oenny
a Bentley that's all I'm saying I'm
seeing on Google Dave one to $1 to
$5,000 per implanted tooth is what the
going rate is so if he's talking
many many teeth could be 50 Grand it
could be okay depending all right Google
we know Google's right always right I go
to WebMD for all of my health needs yeah
yeah if you go to WebMD you're dying you
have three days to live that's it you
got three days to live everything is
three days to live or it's a minor head
cold three days to live and $1,000 a
tooth yeah three days to live yeah I I
seriously shop it Jenny that's what I
would do and then if you need 20,000
bucks slow down your you got 170 coming
in slow down your de snowball enough at
the speed of the urgency to come up with
the 20K if you're going to wait 10
months that' be $22,000 a month we're
going to do it over 10 months if we need
to do it right now we're going to have
to stop everything and do it over two or
three months right and so uh however
quick you can build up the 20K but it is
going to impact and slow down your de
snowball
speed because this is something you have
to deal with your your
husband's uh dental health does matter
we're not we're not blowing that off hey
thanks for the call open phones at
88255 225 thank you for joining us
America we appreciate you being here and
uh I mean this is how it's done boys and
girls we you know it's
um man George your brand new book coming
out next week Tuesday January 16th
called Breaking Free from broke the
ultimate guide to more money and less
stress you can see right there on the
cover there's a millennial holding up
the wall that's all you need to know so
if they if Millennials can hold up walls
then they can do anything right I had to
flex my muscles there that's it you want
yeah that I've got an interesting
question about this Dave people keep
asking well how is this different from
The Total Money
Makeover and it's been an interesting
question because I believe it's very
different the first two-thirds of this
book are really unpacking probably the
most in-depth we've ever done on the
toxic money culture all of the different
types of debt with research from you
know these last few years I mean if you
want some in-depth stuff on any of the
financial things moving around out there
this book's got it in there and Total
Money Makeover has none of that Total
Money Makeover is the baby steps it's
how to do it how to do the baby steps
yeah this book has a just I cover the
baby steps and I go cats out of the bag
but we're going to have to unpack why to
do the baby steps what's underneath this
all the research in this and the snark
in this is incredible so but let me tell
you living on less than you make living
on a budget being generous getting out
of debt saving money is going to be in
every Ramsay
book in one form or another nothing new
Under the Sun says we didn't we didn't
change that for Jade or George or Rachel
it's going to be there so uh every
Ramsey money book anyway it's not going
to be in John delon's book but even part
of it's in John delon's book so there so
so be sure to pre-order January 15th is
your last day to get $100 in bonus items
at ramseys solutions.com store thank you
to so many many of you who have already
done that I hope this book helps you
take the right next step with your
finances this
[Music]
year hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the church kill
mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to Churchill mortgage.com
today to learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us America
we're glad you're here open phones at
5225 our question today is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services no more scrolling through pages
of Internet results neighborly is the
one place you'll find a variety of Home
Service professionals that you can rely
on to do the job right or neighborly
will make it right that's the neighborly
Done Right promise learn more at
neighborly decom Ramsey today's question
comes from Sherry in Vermont hello Mr
Ramsey can you please explain why the
most common form of income mentioned is
gross income not net income when
discussing budgets and personal finances
I find it confusing because in my mind
the deducted taxes don't count you can't
spend what you owe the government so if
you include that it makes it seem like
you have more discretionary income than
you actually do thank you for the
clarification well um it depends on what
we're talking about the problem is
honestly um Sher
the too many people don't know
how do I say this delicately they don't
know what to flip their own money is I
mean so here's the thing if you make uh
$60,000 a year that's $5,000 a month
gross before taxes but if I ask you what
your net is and you say
$2500 which is $330,000 a year then I've
got to go try to figure out because you
apparently don't
know whether you have taken out 401K out
of that health insurance out of that
whether you have your car payment
deducted out of that and it's going to
your credit union that's not real net
but it is what you're coming home with
because you had all this other crap
taken out of your check and so a lot of
people don't really understand that net
what you get your take-home pay because
people have other various things taken
out is not germine I can tell what's
going on with your gross but I can't and
I know about what your taxes are based
on your gross and but uh and then I can
do the calculations while we're sitting
here to help you move towards getting
out of debt but I'm well aware if you
make $60,000 a year $5,000 a month that
you're not getting home with after
federal income tax
withholding $5,000 I know that but I
also know that you should be getting
home with a lot more than some of you
are because some of you have too much
taken out of your check your deductions
are wrong some of you have uh other
things that aren't taxes coming out of
your check like I just mentioned and so
when I say take when someone gives me
take-home pay I really don't know
what they're talking about because it
could mean so many different things but
I can back into it from gross and know
where you stand so that's why I use that
figure but it's not because I don't
realize there's taxes taken out it's
because I do realize there's a bunch of
other crap taken out of other people's
checks and sometimes they're so confused
by that because you really can talk to
somebody that a $5,000 gross and they're
getting home with half of that or if
they have a regular income they can be
very confused based on what's going to
come in that month what's your take home
pay so the hey what what did you make
last year if you're self-employed you
know you don't have a take- home pay MH
you know and unless you're set yourself
up on a salary and you've done
withholding then did you do your
withholding correctly because way too
many people get a tax refund which means
you have too much coming out of your
check for taxes it doesn't mean Santa
Claus lives in Washington DC and so if
you have too much coming out of your
check and then I use your take-home pay
number to try to help you with your
finances then I've participated in your
in your stupid mistake you know and so
that that's why we do that because the
only reliable number to back into things
is your gross and yes obviously Sher we
do realize it comes out taxes and we use
some round numbers too when we're just
on a five minute phone call we're not
digging in to the exact mathematics but
you your brain is the lady a few minutes
ago 170,000 is her gross and I know
she's not getting home with 170 but also
know that with 170 gross she could come
up with 15 or 20,000 bucks for her
husband's teeth I mean I can they're
taking home eight or nine they could
probably live rocket surgery to do that
basic math right there and so uh but I
don't have to actually go well let's see
her tax withholding and I don't have you
don't have to do all that she's out of
170 minus income taxes minus food she
can still find 20 to perix Res his teeth
I mean that's just just doesn't take a
you know a sixth grader to do that so uh
hypothetically but that's why that's why
uh I know you can't spend what you ow
the government I'm well aware of that
they they take so much from me that
I can't breathe Aiden is with us in
Tampa Florida hi Aiden welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi how you doing better than I
deserve what's
up great um I'm 22 I just got married in
October
congratulations thank you thank you yeah
we make around
$115,000 right now we both contribute
10% to our Ira for work we're debt free
and our question is around housing we
have enough for about a 10% down payment
on the house we want to buy and our
question is should we go ahead and do
that and pay the PMI or should we wait a
couple years and just save up
20% well I doubt it' take you a couple
years you probably do it by a year from
now couldn't
you yeah I think so I think the math I
was looking at it' be about a year and a
half okay all right so you'll be a whole
24 years old when you buy your first
house that's the goal yeah that wouldn't
be bad I like that no I just I mean it's
okay to do it the other way but the PMI
is so stinking expensive man I mean it's
75 bucks a month per
100,000 so it's $225 if you do a
$300,000 house what does this House
cost Aiden what's this house going to
cost yeah about a 300,000 is what we're
thinking my uh my wife works for a home
builder so we get a good deal so you got
30 and you want 60 so the question is
how quickly can we save up another 30
Mak 15 you really ought to be able to do
that in a year dude you have other debt
that's what we're thinking you said you
had no other debt at all oh good yeah I
think I'm going to sit down do the
budget and tighten up and say hey we're
not going to buy that thing and we're
going to save for a
house and uh that's what I would do if I
were you guys and you're investing 10%
you're in baby step 3B and so if you so
choose and you wanted to do this in six
months you could pause investing or
bring it down to a match or something
like that in order to speed this up yeah
yeah I think you I think you and if
you're building a house the twoo you're
not going to be closing on it when you
break ground mhm you could break ground
you know next spring one year and uh and
still have time to get the money
together to have the 20% down so I I
like I just don't want to give them PMI
private mortgage insurance folks if you
don't know is foreclosure Insurance it
pays the mortgage company in the event
they have to foreclose on you and they
lose money that's what PMI is it's
private mortgage insurance protects the
lenders not you it protects the lenders
it's not life insurance it's not ins you
are buying someone else an insurance
policy it's a risky borrower fee at $75
a month per 100,000 if you're buying a
$300,000 house that's
$225 a month on top of your interest
that you're throwing away so it it
definitely hurts but I was in the same
spot as Aiden Dave we bought our first
town home was $300,000 it was a new
construction build and every delay I was
happy cuz it was more time we could save
up and so we were able to put down well
over 20% because of that and it allowed
us to pay it off even sooner did did you
you didn't purposefully cause any delays
did you no that's just the construction
business Dave I learned I learned I had
to I had to manage the project myself I
had to show up there and be like that
towel bar is not even centered on the
wall I'm not a construction expert but I
feel like it should be centered wow and
so a lot of things need to that really
happened didn't it yeah it's real life
that's that real you really did do a
towb bar thing didn't you
because that you had too much passion
about that for that so much passion
about the towel bar that's but you know
you've been in Nashville a long time the
amount of construction that's gone up in
the Last 5 Years even is wild and these
Builders you know they're they're moving
as fast as they can but they run into
delays and subcontractors are moving
around and going to the next guy who
will pay him a dollar more and so it can
be it can be tough now things have
slowed down which is great you get a
little more attention on these builds
yeah probably keep the towel bar
centered now keep the towel bar centered
that's all I ask I'm OCD it's got to
stay symmetrical big deal but new builds
as you know Dave they can be a blessing
and they can be a curse and so we were
happy to have it but getting there was a
journey the amount of blue tape on the
walls Dave every little cranny you blue
taped them too I blue taped the heck out
of those walls oh man you're that guy
yeah okay they they didn't like me they
were ready for me to be done yeah got to
get rid of OCD George it's the biggest
purchase of my life Dave I wanted it
done George he's the towel rack guy the
blue tape guy I've complained more at
Chick-fil-A to get the order right let
alone in my house oh you complained to
Chick-fil-A it's happened are you going
to heaven they're not always perfect
they're not always Angels
[Music]
Dave this is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualif ify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Sarah is with us in
Seattle hi Sarah welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey David George thanks for taking
my call how are you better than we
deserve what's
up well my husband and I are pretty
young we're 24 um over the last three
years we've paid off all of our debt you
know college in a car we've paid for our
wedding in cash but since we started
working we've actually tripled our
income so now it's about $400,000 a year
good Lord what do you guys
do we work in Tech in what in
Tech okay they work in Tech in Seattle
so I could guess where that might be
okay well good for you way to go
congratulations you know thank you so
much um and that kind of Le leads to my
question you know as the baby steps lay
out we're moving on to the next phase of
wealth building we've maxed out our
401ks our HSA contributing to an IRA
mutual funds we don't have a desire to
buy a house soon but you know maybe
we'll just save up for a down payment to
be able to do that down the line if we
choose but since neither of us grew up
with this kind of wealth or anywhere
close to it all of it kind of feels
excessive almost so how do you guys
think about what a reasonable amount is
to be saving versus spending you know we
don't want to be excessive Savers and
missing out on generosity and enjoying
the now but also we don't want to be
excessive Spenders so since it's New
Territory I was curious if you could
share your Insight on
that there's a lot of wisdom there well
done very well done thank you um well
the experience that most people have and
I've had it as well is that as your
income increases and it goes places
you've never been before it takes your
emotions a while to catch up which kind
of causes you to ask this
question yeah okay it's like you know
giving extreme example um I mean I own
ramsy Solutions our gross revenues here
are about 300 million a year and I've
got a th team
members we spend more on
coffee than I used to
make you know it's kind of it's kind of
emotionally mindblowing you know what
I'm talking about and so yeah um it's um
uh it's hard to get your head around so
how do you go and it almost feels
immoral or unethical unless you really
start to put some uh you know put put
some help to it to help with the
emotions so one of the things I've
discovered and I I you know when I'm
working for instance with a pro athlete
I'll use this um is we just always say
Sharon and I work off of
percentages we say this percent of our
income um if I get a check in from
publisher Total Money Makeover check
comes in which is usually a pretty nice
check each year uh and that check comes
in a percentage goes to investing a
certain percentage that preset a preset
goes to additional purchases and
enjoyment a preset amount goes to
additional generosity additional
investing uh now 50% of it's gone before
we start cuz 40% goes to taxes and 10%
to tithe cuz we're Evangel iCal
Christians okay so that that that leaves
me the other 50% to split up among fun
investing and additional generosity and
so we just put a percentage on that and
so that's what you can do you can just
say so for instance here you're in baby
step four and you're saving towards a
house so I would put 15% of my income
towards retirement right and you ought
to be doing that anyway that's a
standard baby step move and uh then I'm
going to put x% for enjoyment and then
you kind like have to spend that on
enjoyment even if it feels
weird yeah because when you were
thinking about it not in terms of a
purchase you wanted to make but you were
just thinking about it in a in general
terms and you said okay we're going to
spend 10% of this money on us as an
example I just pull that number out okay
so that's $40,000 of just increased
lifestyle and that's a that would be
leaving 90% for everything else taxes
and generosity and investing and
everything else so that would be you
know we can't really say that would be
crazy but yet then when you get ready to
spend
$40,000 on something oh my gosh what in
the world that feels so weird but it
helps you to do that because oh I've
done my generosity I've done my
investing
and and and these are amounts I came up
or percentages I came up with so cuz
your income could go to 600,000 then
what are you going to do I don't want to
I wouldn't use amount I would use a
percentage that's really helpful I think
that's exactly my wor not worry I mean
what a bless problem to have but um you
know as we're 24 so presumably this
isn't going to be the peak of our income
and so thinking about it as percentages
is so helpful I I hadn't thought about
that before yeah it it'll keep you from
uh underdoing an area or overdoing an
area yeah because you thought about it
you thought about it in ratios when your
head was calm not when you were cuz if
you wait until you're looking at an
opportunity to support a thing with
generosity a Ministry or something
you're emotionally involved
then and so I you know I want to help
that thing I want to I want to cause I
want to help those people with that
situation uh these hungry kids or
whatever it is right by then by then
you're already you're already deep into
it and then you start going well you
know I don't know if this is right or
not and I maybe you too much and you
could do too much you could get all
caught up in the you know the beautiful
little children that need some food and
you could just give away you know you go
crazy and so that's you that really
helps to lay out ratios yeah well I
think of it as that kind of tire and you
don't want a flat tire if you're only
saving and you're not enjoying it you
call to the show and you're just
clenched fists and uh you know some
people can be very very generous but i'
I have a hard time finding people who
went broke being generous so that's a
great one to flex and the spending side
people call in and say Dave I've been
following you for 30 years I can't
stomach spending money and Dave's like
go force yourself to do something fun
and so if you look at it thr through
those three buckets it becomes
easier save spend I mean the first time
you spend XYZ that you've never spent
makes you want to throw up on something
you go what in the world am I have I
lost my mind even if you're a spender
you sto and question you know am I out
of control here I bought a car that cost
that oh my gosh I used to buy houses for
that you know I mean it's like golly and
so yeah it is emotional and um but you
know the good news is once and the first
time I gave away
$10,000 I thought man I'm rich I mean
only rich people give away $110,000 I
thought this is a big deal and now
$10,000 I mean it's and then you kept up
upping it every year the other year you
gave away a million dollars in a day and
that was a big goal for you to fun to
get there and so but it wasn't I mean I
couldn't even I thought I was so cool in
one sense I gave away $10,000 you know
and then and then I was like wow you
know uh but then you get satiated to it
and what will keep you from going out of
control is to have some boundaries and
those those ratios are good boundaries
it's kind of the opposite of Lifestyle
creep when you're not living on less
than you make this is someone following
the plan going how do I increase the
right way Mike's in Washington DC hey
Mike welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey dve how are you better than I
deserve what's up
man uh not not too much I have a
question so I my employer offers a 401k
and uh I just finished up my first year
work maxed out my contributions to it uh
found out we have the ability to make
Roth contributions great so I I switched
from 12% pre-tax to 12% Roth awesome and
uh so now that I'm contributing making
Roth contributions I lose that deduction
that I was getting for making free tax
contributions correct and other other
than an IRA a traditional IRA I'm
curious what other avenues there are to
kind of make up for losing that
deduction okay let let's let's reframe
that because you you
traded a pre-tax tax
deduction making the entire account
taxable when you get ready to take it
out so if you have a million dollar in
your 401k at retirement 100% of it's
taxed if it's a pre-tax 401K you traded
that for taxfree you didn't lose the tax
deduction you traded a small tax
deduction for a huge taxfree gain so
that's a good trade I'll make that trade
every day I hate taxes but not bad
enough to to just you know do something
stupid like avoid a Roth no you did the
right thing with the Roth there are no
big deductions out there this idea that
the the rich people have all the
deductions it's a bunch of crap unless
you run a business or you've got
something you can depreciate you don't
have big deductions out there and don't
go do a traditional just to get a tax
[Music]
deduction
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host Heidi is in Bowling Green Ohio
hi Heidi how are you
hi Dave um I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve Bowling Green Ohio
hometown of Scott
Hamilton it is it is and yeah in the
National Tractor poles and yeah and and
I believe Dave Dave there was an old
runner back in the day Dave wadell you
probably don't know that name but yeah
that was a long time
ago anyway how can I help okay okay so
my question is first I want to say thank
you so much for taking my call and you
are an answer to a bold prayer that I
just said yesterday and I'm so grateful
to get through um but my question is we
my husband and I um we've been blessed
with four kids um that we raised we have
our our baby is a senior in high school
and now um my husband and I are trying
to buckle down and figure out how to
ride this next um season and um to the
best we can financially to you know hit
retirement in a good note we have our
home that we live in and we also have a
5 acre piece of property that has uh
four rentals on it four rental homes it
also has a large barn but we've had a
hard time renting the barn out for um
anything but we have um through this
process of um raising the kids and um
selling business that we had for years
my husband went back to school and um
they called him Grandpa Daddy but he
graduated first in his class so he was
he was a good Granda daddy student he um
but we have we took out two helocs um we
have a heack on our home and a helac on
the rental for what um for what well
what' you buy with that
money we just covered expenses while he
was in school because so he he wasn't
working no he he's yeah he he worked a
little and you weren't working y' y'all
didn't have any money to eat and so you
borrowed money to
eat well I was working but my income was
not going to um was not going to fill
the gap of his not working so how long
did he not work and how much money did
you guys rack
up well he did not work for about a year
um and in that time we had um we went
from I guess over the course of a few
years we went from a really large income
how much do you owe on these two helocs
that's what I'm
asking on the Helo on the first one we
owe
295 what about on the other one and the
the other one is
395 okay so you
borrowed
$70,000 when on the year that he didn't
work and what is his degree
in he is now a substation
electrician okay and what is his income
now well he's still climbing each year
um because he's he's been at his job for
three years now but currently um he
works he is working a lot over time but
he makes
about um
110 okay what do you make and and I'm
I'm currently home okay so you have
$110,000 income you have $70,000 in
helocs from this mess any other debt
well well we have 140 income because we
get rental income from the five
acres so another 30 in rental income you
have any other debt other than the SE
loocks we we have
um no we we drive crappy cars and you're
how old we 52 okay so how quick are you
going to clean up $70,000 making
$40 I I hope I would love to do it in
two years I think you should but but I
don't I would also my other proposal
thought is do we sell the 5 Acres with
the rentals because over the next 10
years
from what like I'm calculating if it
makes a profit of
216,000 I don't know if
um I don't know if it's worth hanging on
to or just trying to sell it for and
what bring
everything I think it would bring I
think it would bring at least my husband
thinks $450 okay she got a half a
million dollars sitting in the middle of
your coffee table
and you don't own this farm would you go
buy
it uh no then sell
it okay if you wouldn't buy it again you
shouldn't keep
it but do you think it's possible to get
out from under the Helo because then
that would be paid for a
total it's possible if you make 140,000
surely to God you can pay off 70 in 2
years it's only 35,000 a year out of 140
you got to struggle through 105 minus
taxes right I think you can do that for
sure and or you can sell the other
property I don't think you're required
to sell the other property but it
doesn't sound to me like you guys are
you're not enjoying it's a headache yeah
it's like you know if you didn't own it
would you go buy it no was an instant
answer you didn't even think about it so
obviously it's not I mean if you if you
wouldn't buy it again folks that means
you need to sell it Whatever It Is other
than your spouse I mean and you said you
only got one more kid at the house if
the baby is a senior in high school so
it might be time you go back to work and
help help speed this process up so you
can retire with dignity cuz you said
that was your goal yeah but if you sold
that and you cleared the helocs and then
you just start pilot stacking cash
towards retirement you're going to be
just fine you're going to be okay it's
just a matter which way is the rest the
way you want to go at it 20 years from
today do you want to own that
farm and um if you ask me that about
several of the properties we own the
answer is yes I very seldom sell a piece
of real estate but occasionally I look
at it and I go God if I I wouldn't buy
that if I had own it that means you got
to get rid of it that means it's time to
move to something else and I've got a
couple of those um uh I have moved a
couple of pieces of real estate over the
years but 90% of the stuff we buy we
keep forever uh that's our goal so but
you know it's okay to move it there's
nothing wrong with it good question
thank you for joining us Canada's on the
line Dale is calling hi Dale welcome to
the Ramsey show how can we help hey hey
guys um I'm just wondering um I hear you
guys talk all the time about um if you
own vehicles with large payments on them
to sell them and downgrade to your
smaller vehicles but I guess my question
is if I've got vehicles with negative
equity how do I do that you have to
cover the negative equity with a new
loan or
savings okay how much negative equity do
you have Dale
uh we have two vehicles and uh a travel
trailer that
we excuse me that we don't use anymore
so we're deciding that we're because
we're not using it we might as well get
rid of it yeah so the trailer let's just
take the trailer what is it
worth um it's worth about uh about 30
and what do you owe on it uh 47 okay so
would you rather have 47 in debt or 17
in debt I'd rather have 17 but I just
wasn't sure if that's the best or if
there's some other options that there's
not another option you got to cover this
you got to cover the the negative in
order to give a clear title to the buyer
and so that's the problem with being
stuck upside down in these things so you
could go to you know your local credit
union and see if they'll give you or the
place that holds the loan and say listen
I'm underwater on this thing this you
got bad collateral here cuz this thing's
only worth 30 i0 47 I'm looking for a
177,000 loan to cover the difference and
get rid of this thing yeah let me sign a
note for the difference and if it's a
local credit union they might do that
for you yeah you know if it's
Trevor trailer Finance Incorporated
they're not going to yeah you know CU
they don't you're going to run in
trouble you're going have to go to the
local credit you borrow the 17 to get
out but I'd rather you be 177,000 in
debt than 47 that'll speed this
especially on a trailer that's sitting
in the yard that you don't use and wish
you hadn't bought so there you go or you
come up with a difference if you got it
in savings or you can come up with it
quickly by the way travel trailers are
not evil but if you're out there sitting
there thinking today that you're going
to go buy a $50,000 one oh gosh and a 50
know that it's going to be worth 30 in
about 45 minutes and so don't Finance it
for sure you know be ready to take the
hit that's how this world works this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships the phone number here is
88255 225 George camel Ramsey
personality host of The George camel
with a k
YouTube
channel that has absolutely exploded in
listenership and subscribers thank you
viewership I guess you say on YouTube
but thanks for doing that the team just
let me know Dave we just hit I think a
record over a million unique viewers in
in the last 28 days on the YouTube
channel so thank you to everyone who's
been tuning in that's the fastest we've
ever gotten to a million on anything on
the Ramsey networks wow fastest we've
had some get bigger obviously this show
and so forth but but the fastest to a
million is you way to go wow I'll take
it take the win nice well the team does
an amazing job and we make those videos
entertaining while informing the people
about personal finance so I appreciate
it if you like this show you'll like
that one Jessica's in New York City
Jessica how are you hi I'm good how are
you better than we deserve what's
up um so my question is so in late 2022
my boyfriend and I invested $100,000 in
my family's fast food franchise business
and then so in 2023 we've since made
11,000 back and that's currently in a
high yield savings account um my
question is should we keep it in that
savings account until we've accured the
initial investment back or should we
reinvest the 11,000 that we've
made okay how much did you put
in I put in 30 my boyfriend put in
70 okay and you made an 11% rate of
return m
wow um so the franchise is not doing
that well
huh
oh I don't know you ought to be making a
lot more than that you ought to be
making more than 11% on a small business
operation okay um okay so so the
11,000 what is really not a joint amount
you a portion of that is yours and a
portion of that's his
correct yeah but for the the purpose of
this question we can view it as a joint
amount I just want to know like if it
was only the 11,000 yeah what what
should it has nothing to do with
recouping your investment I just
wouldn't put any more in this um so I
would I would take that money and just
do something else with it and I would
not view it as a joint account I would
view it as separate because you're not
married and so it's not legally a joint
account you don't you do not have an LLC
managing this you don't have a joint you
don't have any kind of joint venture
agreement this is two individuals that
dump money into an account so it is
separate legally you don't have a choice
in that matter um and so you ought to
separate it and his portion should be
the return on his money and your portion
should be the return on your money and
then you guys go and do with that in
your personal finances each of you not
joint uh what you should be doing but no
I I wouldn't put it back in there um
you've already put enough in there put a
lot in there now if she's talking about
investing the money in instead of having
it sit in the savings account if we're
talking five plus years you know if she
wanted to take that money and put it
into mutual funds or an index fund is
that something that yeah but I'm
guessing they probably have some other
financial goals like getting out of debt
or saving money fors a house that kind
of thing that that money should be
moving moving in those directions even
rather than as an investment but should
I would I roll it back into the
franchise no I sure would not a small
business ought to be returning double
that um
and um so that no I would not thanks for
the call open phones at
88255 225 jasmin's in Cleveland Ohio hi
Jasmine how are
you good how about you guys better than
I deserve what's
up so my father passed away unexpectedly
in
December sorry how old was he thank you
uh 56 oh wow
young I'm sorry we dealing that loss
right now he had one um life insurance
policy um I was awarded 25% of it and
also my 5-year-old daughter was awarded
25% uh both of our portions value at uh
just a little bit over $188,000 each um
my portion we plan to uh me and my
fiance we plan to pay off debt uh with
her portion though um obviously it's
with her I wanted to stay with her but
she's 5 years old and I wanted to know
uh get some advice on what are the best
options to possibly invest it or yeah I
would put it in some mutual funds and a
college fund in a
529 uh go to ramseys solutions.com and
click on
smartvestor and find some of the
smartvestor pros in your area that we
endorse that we tell folks to go see cuz
they have the heart of a teacher and uh
I would I would get her 18,000 sitting
in a
529 um and uh and and then I'll step
over into the other part of your
statement much like the last caller uh
you and your fiance aren't doing
anything until you're
married you are doing things with your
money on your bills don't you dare pay
his bills with
this well we do have plans to uh be
married so
when uh we planned it in the next month
actually okay after you're married after
you're married you have shared accounts
and shared assets but until that ring is
on your finger and this is official do
not use any of your money to pay his
bills
please please for your sake okay now
once you're married then it's all it's
all in where all the money's in the
middle his yours you know my debt your
debt my money your money all that and uh
but but until you're married because if
something happened until you're married
you know you have zero protection on
this so it's just dangerous as crud to
start to to start handling your
financial transactions as if you're
married when you're not in both of these
cases and we take those calls when it
was supposed to go perfectly according
to on paper and then life happened and
it didn't work out and then someone's
going well I paid off your debt and now
we're not getting married what do we do
now well I mean all kinds of things
happen that we don't know are going to
happen and um you know sometimes it's
ugly things and sometimes it's sad
things and other things so please please
please folks do not have join accounts
for your $11,000 when you're not married
do not take your dad's 18,000 from your
Dad's passing away from his life
insurance that he left his daughter and
pay bills for a guy you're not married
to
yet after you're married it's not a guy
you're married to he's now called your
husband now we are one and now yes we
can pay any bills with it whatever
whatever we decide we're going to do but
guys you you cannot treat these things
the same because you're you're going to
get yourself in a pinch and I just we
love you too much to see that happen to
you and um we run into ugly situations
where people misbehave we run into sad
situations where people die we run into
all kinds of things and um we've seen it
all and and you
know as long as you you
know things don't always turn out
exactly like your little plan so until
you're married don't be combining assets
do not buy a house with someone you're
not married to dumber than crud don't do
that I was just talking to you right
then you out there you know who I'm
talking to this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 we're glad you're here Ruth is with
us Ruthie is with us rather in Orange
County hi Ruthie how are
you I'm doing great thank you for taking
my call sure what's
up um so you know I currently live in
California which is I grew up here but
it's High Cost of Living and
we not aside from the house consumer
debts about 150k that we have and I was
thinking about relocating to
Tennessee um as a lot of Californians
have and maybe just either used the
profit from our home here it did
increase in value in a short amount of
time and maybe just get a house cash and
then help speed up the process of
getting us out of
debt I don't know that's a good idea
what is your uh what's your home in
Orange County
worth
um it's about a million
135 okay and what do you owe on
it uh about seven a little over 700,000
I think okay so you got $500,000 in
equity and you have $140,000 in um
debt so that leaves you 350,000 to buy a
house with when you make your move
right yes okay all right well a million
two in Orange county is probably 350 in
some other areas uh not New York City
but it could be in Tennessee for sure um
could be a similar property actually
depending on where in Tennessee you
landed or Texas or Florida or whatever
but um wherever you decide to go uh so
financially obviously that changes
things what does your husband do for a
living what do you do for a
living I am a registered nurse I work
from home um I bring in about 139 a year
he used to be in sales but um you know
he's in his early 50s and kind of aged
out of it really he's he's working with
um special needs kids really at one of
the local high schools now he just got
the job he's bringing about 40K really a
year okay well that's not that hard to
replace then and you can do your job
from anywhere
right yes from anywhere as long as in
the
US okay I keep my same salary really
okay so you you can you know you can
handle the career change you can handle
the real estate change You' be dead free
to make the move um then the only the
bigger question than all of that is
um you know just because it makes
Financial sense doesn't mean that your
family is going to want to do this and
that you're going to be happy and that
you need to do this I mean right you
know I've I've got a good I've got a I
was with a friend of mine last night
that just moved to Nashville from
California and um his wife grew up in
Orange County and you know um they're
they're settling into Nashville it's a
different
culture sure um yeah you know that's
part of the hesitancy either I the other
plan was thinking about maybe just
chugging it through and you know I'm on
baby step too really just trying to get
out of debt and I mean so the answer the
answer to your question is is
financially mathematically everything
you're saying makes sense but that
doesn't mean you should do
it the reason you should do it is is it
makes you happy it causes you to be
excited and you get out of debt and pay
cash for a house not I get out of debt
pay cash for a house and I'm
miserable true so you guys got to would
you still want to move if you didn't
have any debt would you still want to
move to Tennessee the answer is yes this
could be a great move yeah yeah if you
wanted to move to a different state of
any kind start a new adventure but um it
sounds like like my friend's wife who
grew up there her the axis of the world
for her runs through Orange County I
mean the access for me runs through the
middle of Nashville that's where I grew
up and so uh you know where I to moved
to Orange County it'd be different it'
be like being on a different planet you
know and so um pay to see that Dave yeah
it' be different be weird but yeah but
I'm you know you can make you could pay
off 150 making
180 that's not impossible you could do
that in two years so three years you
know it's definitely doable uh if you're
willing to make the sacrifices the
question is where do you want to be 10
years from today living physically
geographically where do you want to be
living and
um then that needs to make your overall
decision in my friend's case they left
California because of the political
situation the ridiculous actions around
the fouchy pandemic and the crazy but
taxes uh they paid cash for their house
here in one year of income tax savings
not living in California wow well we got
no state income tax here in Tennessee
which is another blessing and so that
you know for them it was like you you
know the state of California ran us off
is the way they feel about it well we
saw the migration numbers too it's the
second largest state for losing people
New York lost the most California lost
the next most and um most of them went
to Tennessee Texas and and Geor and
Florida is where it's the three
most uh uh I don't know incoming with
the with the shift in migration we've
had a huge migration but the migration
is completely in all of these cases
caused by the politics and and the taxes
associated with the politics and so um
you know that's you cannot
tax rich people when they can move
away they will leave they don't have to
stay and so this idea we're going to tax
all these rich people and then they all
just load up the truck and head away
from Beverly Hills that is swimming
pools and movie stars so there you go I
mean they they leave buddy I mean that's
what happens and so you see these
migrations and uh so what you've got is
a perfect storm between uh several of
the political issues along with the uh
pandemic issues which are really
political issues is what they came down
to and then you mix in the tax issues
which really is a political issue when
it gets right down to it but these four
you know one or two of them people can
stomach but when you start putting three
four five of these things on there then
people move out of Michigan they move
out of uh which is the third one uh they
move out of California and they move out
of New York it's I mean this is not an
opinion it's a statistical fact um
U-Haul is making a
killing I mean it's like they they they
they you know they think Governor Nome
is just incredible marketing thanks for
the business yeah oh man so um that's
what's going on so Ruthie but I'm not
it's not I'm not saying you're dumb if
you stay cuz honestly I hear sadness in
your voice when you're talking about it
it sounds like you're sad and you don't
want to move somewhere just be sad even
though the math works I I wouldn't do
that if you if you can look at it as an
adventure and a new chapter in our life
and we're excited about this and it'll
be fun and be different and uh whatever
then yeah that's fine but uh but but
only the the math works on what you're
talking about but just because the math
works that's not the only reason to do
it it's one solution doesn't mean it's
the solution exactly exactly Samuel's
with us in Columbus Georgia hi Samuel
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave good afternoon thank you
for taking my call I'm long time
listener so thank you I'm calling to get
some help um and advice on how to best
assist my um mother and her husband who
are both struggling financially and
medically how old are
they both about in their early 60s okay
what's the medical
situations so her husband has had uh two
strokes he had his second stroke at the
beginning of last year around his time
um so he's very very like incapacitated
he has some other residual medical
problems my mom she has high blood
pressure um and um she's also
unfortunately obese mly obese
and the both are but um they're both
partially I mean if you sit down and
Coach them on their money will they take
your
advice
well I I'm not sure sir okay then you
might be wasting your time I mean you
can't make grownup people do stuff it's
there's not a law that allows that so
um you know you could cover a medical
bill but we need to find a sustainable
solution yeah I would sit down with them
and and figure out where we're going and
what are we going to do to get there and
then you can realize what participation
you need to do but if you start throwing
money at this and they're digging a hole
faster than you're filling it in uh
that's not going to work for anybody so
you got to get a holistic approach to
this and that'll help you get
[Music]
there
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 all right let's catch up a little
bit
there is a company called standard and
poor they are one of the companies that
rates things on the stock market the
most famous thing that they rate there's
a company called Dow Jones that has an
average of the industrial companies
which creates the Dow Jones Industrial
Average which is a little strange
because a lot of the companies are not
industrial anymore that are part of that
aage old timey term but it come it comes
from the you know when America was more
uh manufacturing driven than it is today
uh the SNP standard and poor rates the
top the largest 500 companies that are
publicly traded meaning their stock is
sold on what we call the big board the
New York Stock Exchange so these are the
largest 500 companies that sell stock in
America and that means they're have a
that the as this group of companies goes
is a good indication of what the economy
is doing it's a good indication
certainly of what the stock market is
doing because basically they make up the
stock the vast majority of the stock
market so the top 500 companies on the
New York Stock Exchange is called the
SNP standard and poort S&P 500 now
that's important because that's actually
a better way of
measuring what the stock market is doing
than the Dow is okay or the Dow Jones
Industrial Average or any other measure
for that matter this is a very generic
measure and people in the financial
world use the S&P 500 as a as a plum
line to tell what the market is doing so
if a if a mutual fund for instance
outperforms the S&P 500 that means the
mutual fund is making better returns
than the market as a whole if it
underperforms the S&P 500 it makes less
returns so all that's important um nice
article James our producer pulled up for
us if the S&P 500 hits a new all-time
high in
24 you can expect a strong year of gains
to follow according to n Davis research
the investment firm crunched the numbers
and found that when the S&P 500 hits at
least one record high in a given
year that Year's median return is about
15% so what they're saying is is that
when the when the stock market tops out
and has a new record that is almost
always a year that you get great returns
well duh obviously if the stock market's
hitting a new record you ought to be
getting great returns it kind of makes
sense right so good foreshadowing guys
yeah but I mean it makes sense it's an
it's an interesting it is it is a valid
statistical correlation so I like I like
the study the S&P 500 has tended to post
double digigit gains in years with
record highs uh Ned Davis research said
the data point highlights two typ iCal
characteristics of the stock market that
strength begets more strength and that
stocks don't typically Crash from
all-time highs uh so just because it
goes way up generally means it's going
to go up it doesn't mean it's going to
go right back down and that makes sense
of course too of course this stas is not
a slam dunk uh the S&P is less than 2%
away from hitting a new all-time high if
it were to do that in the next day or
two or the next month or two then a uh
you know a the historical data indicates
that you're going to have a great year
which also makes sense because it
wouldn't have hit a high if it wasn't
had moved towards a great year but it
doesn't just jump up there and then jump
down uh so all this to say we're close
to hitting a new record ever in the
history of the stock market it up and if
it hits that that is a great indicator
that 24 is going to be a great year to
have invested uh which means that if
you're waiting until after after the
presidential election in November to do
your investing that's probably a dumb
idea if you got some money you're
sitting on right now I would buy your
mutual fund like tomorrow right now and
if you're thinking about pulling all
your money out because you saw some
headlines don't do that either yeah we
found that if you just ride this roller
coaster over time you're going to hit a
new record high and a new record high
and those and then it's going to go down
and then it's going to come up and then
it's going to go down and then it's
going to come up this is how life works
I mean it's how the real estate it's how
the real estate market works it's how
mutual funds work it's how the whole you
know stock market works the S&P 500 all
this does that so here's the deal you
got 100,000 bucks and you wait till
November and this Market hits and does
what this study indicates and it makes
let's say it makes 15% which was the
average the median okay so $100,000 and
you don't invest it you wait till
November and uh the market goes up 15%
what'd you lose
$15,000
because you didn't do what I just said
to do invest so stock and let me just
tell you real estate's exactly the same
place right now is real estate going to
go down no it's not we have a tremendous
shortage of housing there's more buyers
even in a sluggish slow Market where
people are sitting on the sidelines
because interest rates spiked up now
they're coming back down they're coming
off Sidelines in the last two weeks like
never before for but
um if you wait a year to buy a house
because you're somehow waiting to time
the market you've got this mysterious
Insight that you think things are going
to go down you're
wrong and if you wait a year to invest
in the market because you're waiting on
the market to come down you're going to
miss
it and if I'm wrong give it another 12
months and I won't be wrong cuz it'll
come up I mean really uh so I I got to
tell you what would dve what is Dave
Ramsey doing right now
buying period investing period I'm not
waiting
on the clash of the old men Trump and
Biden I'm not waiting on two8 80y Old
80y olds to have an MMA to decide what
I'm going to do cuz who who the crap
knows one of them may break a hip well
it's it's more like bumper cars that are
running out of battery bumping into each
other more than a clash it's like two
Muppets the dirt the old men Muppets
right so Statler and Waldorf is that
them that's him oh my gosh so you don't
wait on this don't sit don't watch Fox
News and CNN and and let your butt sit
on the bench get in the game shoot the
ball fire pull the trigger whatever
whatever metaphor we need to use to
cause you to actually do the investing
Sports Weaponry whatever it takes
whatever it takes to get you moving here
we'll do we'll go whatever whichever
direction you need to go and this
validates a lot of what you've been
saying for 30 years Dave we looked at
historical data and the S&P 500 average
annual return is 10 to 12% and they're
saying right here this is going to could
be a year about 15% median return and
people always go Dave I'm not getting
that in my account well yeah dummy not
in a given one month period will you see
that but over time the average is the
average that's how averages work Aver I
think we all need to go back to basic
map statistical yeah these these uh
these these sixth grade MTH math classes
that people flunked but yeah that that's
the thing so so all of this to say boys
and girls please be steadily investing
please the people that invest are the
ones that have money there's a high
correlation between people who save
money invest money that have money hello
why was that deep you know if you don't
if you don't put any money in the
account please don't expect any money to
be in the account why is that hard well
there but just keep keep doing it just
keep doing it just keep there's a lot of
fear and that's why I love you know
working with a financial Pro uh smart
Vestor Pro great great person to work
with to reach out to a financial adviser
an investment Pro and go help me
understand this and you make the
decisions and they're not going to pull
the money out for you you are calling
the shots here and they're going to help
you understand the perspective that
we're showing you on the show today yeah
you can pull up the historical data and
look at the track records look at the
trend lines it's really not hard to
understand I mean it's really not I mean
if you pull up in a neighborhood and
there's cars up on blocks and the
gutters are falling off the houses and
the place everything you see needs weed
eaters then then you know and then you
pull up the MLS data on that
neighborhood and you see the values have
been going down it's not a it doesn't
require rocket surgery to figure out
that this thing's going down in value I
mean you know it's is not hard and if
you pull up in the neighborhood and
everything's manicured and it looks like
freaking Leave it to Beaver lives there
you know and you go pull up MLS data on
that you're going to see a line up and
to the right hello well it doesn't take
a rocket surgeon to figure that out
either go buy a house in that
neighborhood this is these are trend
lines it's historical data you can watch
this stuff this is the ramsy
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
our scripture of today Proverbs 13:3
those who guard their lips preserve
their lives but those who speak rashly
will come to ruin Robert Frost said half
the world is composed of people who have
something to say and and and can't and
the other half who have nothing to say
and keep saying
it well since we're on the air with a
live mic we pretty much have to fill up
the time so uh guilty is charged Dave's
going to keep saying it guilty is
charged all the time Robert is in
California hey Robert welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey Mr Ramsey I just wanted to say
I'm a huge fan uh my economics teacher
for my senior year in high school
introduced me to you uh through the
Ramsey Solutions investment
calculator um wow just to yeah just to
let you know uh the main problem at hand
is my father is pretty much not allowing
me to get a part-time job while I'm a
full-time college student that's like
the main issue at hand um the background
on it though is my father came to this
country uh as a refugee during a Civil
War in his home
country and he has a bunch of brothers
and sisters and they ran into a cycle uh
because they never really had any
guidance uh through financial where the
second that they would get a job which
was minimum wage or you know close to
minimum wage they would spend all of
their money they wouldn't save they
wouldn't try to invest they wouldn't do
anything with their money they would
just spend it all and you know even now
we're still see I have a bunch of uncles
and aunts I don't have a single uncle or
Aunt that is financially well off the
only person in my family that is
financially well off is my father and
that is because of my mother and because
because of your mother's discipline or
she brought money to the table my
mother's discipline my mother uh should
up it was to the point where there's a
story my what country did he come from
uh El Salvador say again El Salvador
it's a salvad okay got you okay all
right and um I had to put the Tennessee
um Accent on there to understand okay
and um El Salvador no I'm kidding but
the but anyway the uh
um all right so what's your dad do for a
living He is a CHP
offy okay and you are and he is paying
for your college uh my mother is paying
for my college well your parents are
paying for your college and you live at
home yeah yes I live at home okay all
right well
um you come like I do from a culture of
Honor so honoring your father is very
important would you agree with that
absolutely okay that's a good thing and
so
um number one
you're not going to work unless he's
going along with
it and and that's honoring him and
that's honoring your mom writing the
checks for you to go to school you're
going to go along with their plan okay
now then the next then the next thing is
is there any way you get a hearing with
him and um you know what I might do is
say uh dad I have admired your work
ethic and Mom's work ethic and
discipline and I think I can do some
work and not be irresponsible with it
and would you would would you coach me
Mentor me and let me try it for one
semester with you watching my behaviors
and see if I get out of
line and let's let's run an experiment
dad and the only way I would do that
though is if I can do it in honor you
Dad
yeah okay and so I want to honor your
request but I'm asking for you to help
me try this as an experiment if the
experiment goes the way you think it's
going to I won't ask again and I'll go
through school without working if the
experiment goes well and I'm able to do
this without any kind of debt and I'm
able to do it without becoming
irresponsible due to working which is
his fear if I understood you
right then then Dad then then maybe
maybe the experiment turned out positive
and maybe we can extend that would would
why don't we try this but I need your
help to to to make sure this is being
done the way you want it done
dad that's different than you rebelling
and saying you know in a sense using the
attitude the old man has no clue so
you're going to do whatever you want to
do I I would never endorse you doing
that no absolutely um it biggest role
model yeah yeah and it would work Robert
what was your goal in working parttime
what would you do with that
money well to give you some background
um I followed up with Mr Ramsay since I
was 17 I I remember coming home to my
mom because my mom has a better credit
score than my dad does and begging her
to uh let me piggyback off her credit
card as a 17-year-old and because of
that now I have a 750 credit score with
my own credit cards well you didn't get
that from
us oh no I we didn't you I decided to
take a because of you I decided to take
a bunch of financial classes in my high
school oh okay okay yeah and so what are
you gonna do with this
money invest it I just want to I you
know it's this is a point where in order
to get any type of income I've been
having to do side hustles behind my
dad's back I do computer repairs for my
friends uh I do digital repairs as in
you know I do it work uh across the
internet on Twitter um even one of my
friends has contacted me to open up an
Commerce business with him I like I have
been trying to get any sort of income
under the table uh I already have my
emergency fund set up to
over, uh and then in flat cash I have
around $300 and I've been investing like
a dollar a day just for the past year
into the Vanguard S&P 500 just a dollar
a day yeah so Dad you risked your life
for our family to have an opportunity to
start in the land of the
free and uh part of part of the free is
free enterprise and part of the free is
the ability to go into the marketplace
and earn and uh I I want you to walk
beside me and show me how you think I
ought to do that in a way that's
responsible U that's a lot better than
under the table
hiding and deceiving your father you
don't want to do that that's not going
to turn out well for you so good
question sir good question honored to
have you in our listening audience we
appreciate you being there Janna is with
us in Athens Georgia Janna right quick
for a run out of time what's up hey real
quick um I'm curious on how I get
started on with my budget when I have so
much looming debt over us I'm really
been laser focused I'm trying to get our
financial situation fixed since before
the holidays and when I try to look at
the budget and I'm thinking about the
four walls it it it's it's hard for me
to navigate where to even begin so can
you cover the four walls right now food
you utility shelter Transportation how
much money do you have left after
covering those um barely anything what's
your income and so my income between my
husband and I is 82,000 a year and how
much debt um so we actually not counting
our house for like
$115,000 in debt and that's all been
accured since we bought the house it's
all house debt yeah you you're not
spending $882,000 on food shelter
clothing Transportation you're saying
after your debt payments personal loans
and that's not that's your personal
loans are not four walls your four walls
are your basic necessities so there's
only one way out of this you got to make
more money sell all the crap you bought
and decrease your expenses and use all
the extra margin at the debt smallest to
largest balance how much do you owe on
your
cars um between both of them 149 they're
not the problem okay M yeah so I don't
know what else you bought yeah let's get
you into the every dollar budgeting app
a we'll pay for it and uh the premium
version and get you started here and um
there's a great paycheck planning tool
in there that will help and we'll go
Ahad and put you in Financial Peace
University so you guys can do this but
the two of you are going to have to sit
down together and figure out what of our
lifestyle we're going to cut what we're
going to do to get our income up and our
outgo down and that's what George is
saying and he's exactly right so hold on
Austin I'll pick up we'll get you signed
up for every bit of that so the four
walls are basic food and that includes
no eating out electricity and water
utilities does not include cable okay
that's not a
necessity it includes clothing although
you probably don't need any you probably
got enough to wear if you're up against
the wall uh shelter so you got to pay
the house payment or rent and
transportation you got to keep the cars
running so gas in the tank so you can
get to work and that's it that's your
that's your four walls everything else
is not a necessity everything else is a
bad Monopoly game that puts us sour the
ramsy show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus